the parole hearing in Nevada for OJ
Simpson has concluded and the
Commissioner says they are taking a
recess to deliberate so it wasn't an on
the spot we heard what we needed to hear
and thus that's that again I don't know
if that's the way things go but while
things are on recess we sync that is
perfect timing to welcome into our show
set back once again the longtime host of
The Amazing Race on CBS as directed and
is starring in a new documentary called
lieu ride he is Phil Keoghan good to see
a Phil how are you very good yeah now we
just uh were talking about you asked
because the last time you were here you
said it becomes more of a man cave each
so you can come in more and more of a
manly cable though I just noticed
there's a lot of alcohol will display
but there doesn't seem to be a lot of
consumption
I noticed that like some of the same
wine bottles that were on the Shelf when
I was here two years ago yes they're
still sitting there and and I don't know
who does your dusting but there's dust
on your one well my house the comedian
and actor of Michael Rapaport does the
dusting force around here because he
lost a fantasy football bet with me uh
and had to clean up here on the rich I
like to speak to Michael about his
yushin procedures and you also said you
guys have a beer every now and then and
I said not really but Brockman has a
birthday coming up on Sunday and I
guessed his age at 43 and you and
apparently I'm Way off or I think you're
spot-on right Chris how old are you
going to be on Sunday with 37 look at 37
43 kind of the same thing well if this
was another job you look great for 86
yeah it's by the way this is another
game on CBS it's like the price is right
when you have gone over and we have some
nice parting gifts for you say no yeah
like some of your wine
so tell me buddy I know tell me about a
law ride the documentary that you you
rode the 1928 yes I loved it I loved
underdog sports stories I found this
great book it was about the first
english-speaking team to ride in the
Tour de France and one writer in
particular a guy from my hometown of
Christchurch New Zealand and nobody I'd
never heard of him turns out he was a
seven-time New Zealand champion and even
pro right
that I know who ride from New Zealand
they'd never heard of them so in 1928 he
teams up with three Australians they get
on a ship they go six weeks at sea with
one set of rollers you know those
training rollers and six weeks at sea go
to France turn up in Paris line up
against the best riders in the world who
completely wrote them off and said what
are you guys doing here why are you
coming here with your antiquated bikes
from down under and in those days the
bikes were twice as heavy as they are
today they had no gears there were heavy
steel bikes most of the roads were
unsealed the the course was about 1,200
miles longer than the modern course is
today and it just so happens the 1928
Tour de France had the highest attrition
rate out of any Tour de France in
history 168 riders started 41 finished
it was designed by Omri to grunge in
1903 as it was meant to be a racer where
his ideal race was only one guy would
completely circumnavigate France and
make it back from Paris back to Paris in
the Tour de France that's how he wanted
it so these stages were insane the
winning time of stage 9 which is called
the death stage the winning time in 1928
was 18 and a half hours the winning time
over the Pyrenees over 20,000 vertical
feet of climbing and 200 miles on that
day so it's not so much the 200 miles
it's the fact that they were climbing
slow as five six miles an hour up these
mountains how low what was your time in
Morocco we were shooting a movie it took
us 23 and a half hours I've never been
so completely and utterly shattered in
all my life I mean we we were delusional
we were we really lost a track track of
time we're riding up the tormal a which
is the most famous mountain in the Tour
de France ever and we're in the middle
of the night arriving up there
this this movie could what we decided to
do in order to honor Harry and his mates
was retrace every mile go through every
town stick to the exact schedule in 26
days completing 22 stages 3338 miles
climbing more than 132,000 vertical feet
on original 1928 by
with no gears my follow-up question has
to be why I think Oh therapy why I'm in
therapy confettis I mean it to use the
obvious analogy this did this is an
amazing race what did I mean an actual
amazing opportunity that you took
advantage of I felt they make a race
yeah I felt the story really had to be
told and because all the riders are gone
and because all the witnesses watching
the tour in 1928 are all gone I thought
the only way to really tell his story
was rather than taking the traditional
documentary approach from the outside
and look back that if we put ourselves
in the story and we went through what
they went through we could tell the
story from the inside and then juxtapose
when we wrote it in 2013 with what was
happening in 1928 with archival footage
so we actually cut back and forth
between their story and our story the
story's about them but by us going
through the journey we were able to then
I think articulate to the audience what
it was like and how hard those races
were compared to the modern Tour de
France and and then we also wanted to
make it epic we wanted to make it big so
we were the first documentary feature
film to shoot with an f55 sony camera in
4k and then on Juno which is a French
lens company loaned us over 400 thousand
dollars worth of beautiful French zoom
lenses very fast lenses lens that could
shoot in the night so that's why we've
got it now in theaters around actually
it's in seven countries but in the
United States people are able to see the
film because we want people to see it on
a big screen you know before we shot
this in the what is the equivalent of
super 35 millimeter films it looks
incredible I mean just incredible just
on a television screen well Scott
Shelley was the DP I've worked with him
since 1992 an incredible sugar
incredible stamina but this was not a
story rich that I could go out and sell
I was one of those stories that I had to
go and make first before you know got
selected for South by Southwest and and
did really well in a number of festivals
it was one of those things where as like
if we were going to do it we had to do
it on
on our own so we raised a little bit of
money but if we were very high-end with
the technology but then as far as the
crew it was my mom my dad my wife and
producing partner my best friend Scott
shooting backwards on a motorbike an ex
California Highway Patrol officer a
friend of mine who's from Israel who's a
great shooter it was my brother who did
navigation so it was it was grassroots
it was it was guerilla filmmaking using
the latest technology and then what I
will tell you is I will never try to
shoot a film while I'm taking on such a
huge physical challenge because that
just about killed me and it was you know
we almost had a mutiny in the crew well
at least you had your next of kin right
nearby there you know I mean unless you
had that Phil Keoghan the host of the
Amazing Race and the director and star
of lowrider documentary that is just
striking to say the least right here on
the Rich Eisen show why do you think
cycling isn't as popular as perhaps you
think it should be well well in Europe
it is I mean in Europe it's it's the
biggest well it is the biggest spectator
sport in the world I mean if you and and
there really is nothing like the Tour de
France when you think that it's spread
out over three weeks that it covers the
thousands of miles that it does and all
these little towns and although you've
seen the people that line these
mountains that camp out days beforehand
where what other sport do spectators get
that close to their sporting heroes
where they literally can reach out and
touch them unfortunately sometimes
sometimes yes remember eddy merckx was
punched Eddy Merckx probably the
greatest cyclist ever 525 professional
wins so it's an extraordinary event I
think you know in America it's actually
a pretty big sport but we also have some
pretty extraordinary sports in America
you know we like football yep we have
baseball there isn't a lot of room for a
sport that's really big in Europe to
kind of muscle its way in here in
America but there's no doubt that we
have some extraordinary writers in the
US and aus didn't ride in the tour which
is interesting they didn't ride on the
tour until 1980 the British didn't ride
in the tour until the 1950s and so
that's why this story to me it's so
pertinent about
the first english-speaking team won New
Zealand of three Australians 1928 I mean
so they were way way ahead so I think in
the future we're going to see people
take more of an interest in American
writers I think it'll it'll grow well I
know this year's tour is is exciting
that it's Youngman in quite some time it
comes to a conclusion over the weekend
yet and you know it's real tight
it's very tight yet for the first four
writers if I'm not mistaken they're
separated by about 30-something seconds
room is barely holding the lead right
now but there is a time trial coming up
and now some of the mountain stages I
what I love about the Tour de France is
and and one of the things that we really
tried to get across with with this film
is that it's so much more than just the
race it's the culture it's a little bit
like people who look at baseball and
they just look at the game if they don't
know and they don't understand the
history and they don't understand those
who came before the Babe Ruth's and all
of those people who are a part of the
history when you watch baseball you're
watching it not only just for what
you're seeing but also for all the stats
and for the history and Tour de France
has that element to it Phil Keoghan is
here in the Rich Eisen show I'd like to
take a 60-second break we'll come back
talk a little Amazing Race yes it's such
a popular coming back for season 32
unbelievable season 3-0 which is
remarkable and I'd like to use the
cycling ignorance of the two American
ignoramuses over there Chris and Mike
let's not let's not call them ignorant
well okay uh to what's a little harsher
sort savants I'll go in the other
direction
yeah good there they're cycling ignorant
guys that make you look good rich come
on let's be on there yeah I'd like to
play the game of pharmaceutical or
cyclists mmm now I'm sure you know most
of the names of the cyclists and well I
know some but you know you never know
I'm like Laura thumped well I'd like I
think what I'd like to do is they can
play you can be a phone-a-friend for
them i engineer across and the great
news is it's kind of a 50/50 anyway it
is that a 50/50 an opponent I don't give
you a second opinion Phil Keoghan is
here 60 seconds we'll talk Amazing Race
and pharmaceutical or cyclist the OJ
parole hearing is in recess that's
what's going on back in 60 seconds on
the Rich Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Phil
Keoghan is here of the Amazing Race on
CBS is returning for season 30 that is
truly unbelievable what is the strangest
sequence you have ever laid witness to
in all those years well there that show
there are a number that just you stick
out Charla caring and Charla who was a
small person carrying a piece of meat
that seemed to be larger than her
running down the street in a challenge
this huge piece of meat in Argentina but
perhaps one of the more humorous moments
was when the teams were asked to
transport big wheels of cheese from the
top of a hill to the bottom and the
cheese carrying devices that they have
broke and these massive wheels of cheese
took off down the hill and the teams
were dodging these rolling pieces of
cheese in Switzerland and the locals who
had had a couple of drinks were just
they just thought it was the craziest
thing they'd ever seen these Americans
like scattered all over the hillsides
would be big bowls of chief rolling down
and thank goodness there was a fence at
the bottom because otherwise I think the
cheese's would have made it all the way
into downtown and who knows we could
have had a you know this sort of could
have been some calamities what now we've
also had some athletes have been on The
Amazing Race right yeah we had we've had
NFL players we had NHL players we've had
baseball players snowboard guys
professional rodeo riders I think if out
of out of the 29 seasons we've only ever
had a professional athlete professional
athletes win once oh we did have a Conor
O'Leary with his dad he was a
professional cyclist and they won see
during 25 the or 24 I'm sorry okay 24
unbelievable but just being a
professional athlete doesn't mean you're
going to do well in amazing no I mean
look when you it doesn't matter how much
money you've made as a professional
athlete when your cheese carrying device
breaks and Switzerland is yeah I mean
there's nothing you can do and more pro
athletes are probably more you know apt
to growing their cheese carrot devices a
circuit is so powerful are you ready to
help these guys in we did this
two weeks ago yes same games or what we
did it was either pharmaceutical or
phenom on the futures all-star game the
the bright and the the best in the
brightest yes coming up to the farm
system to Major League Baseball held a
baseball game prior to the all-star
future all-star so you had a guess just
by hearing the name is it in
pharmaceutical or a future all-star now
in honor of you the director and star of
law ride the documentary showing you
riding the cycling the 1928 course of
the Tour de France which is coming to
its 2017 conclusions weekend we're about
to play pharmaceutical or cyclist
pharmaceutical or sight cyclist
I like that did you like the bell ring I
did whose voice was that was it I don't
know whose that was radio Bob okay
always for the rich shots just a voice
in okay so Phil Keoghan is here these
are music yes we gotta have music okay
okay so now first I'm excuse you Phil
now brockman or Delta fo you may use
Phil Keoghan
as a lifeline as a live and remember I'm
a 50/50 because I might not know yeah
okay first the last time so I should be
like your first mic till Tufo we have to
alternate though okay we alternate Liz
I'm gonna stop arguing please Phil
Keoghan is gonna wonder if you know what
we're doing
oh no you guys know what you're doing
like every time I come back this place
is getting bigger and love it yeah okay
here we go the first word entresto
entresto is interesti-- a pharmaceutical
or a cyclist in the Tour de France Mike
Delta foe
cyclist diamond I agree cyclist actually
entresto is a medicine for blood
pressure that increases levels of
certain proteins in the body that
dilates blood vessels please consult
your doctor before taking and contrast
oh really that's crazy you know that
well I've got some with me I mean I you
guys okay Brock when you're first up
you're first up now yeah Contador
Contador is Contador a pharmaceutical or
a cyclist
brockman cyclists
you can happen you ask Phil Keoghan if
you need help I'm gonna wait on the
Lifeline acht
I say cyclists - I'm with Brockman I
miss Phil he's a cyclist he is part of a
team truck sega Fredo
for Spain a virtual continent I think
he's won twice and yeah he's in
extraordinarily for the fastest climb up
one of the club's yesterday yeah that's
Phil okay breaking news and confirming
or is not bound to go bounces on the
pedals when he climbs I'm counting to
watch next one sty bar Oh
ty bar st ybar pharmaceutical or cyclist
Mike del 2fo pharmaceutical brockman so
Cogan's here if you need your help yeah
Phil what do you think on this buddy a
cyclist a pharmaceutical Phil Keoghan
you know I know it kind of looks like a
it looks sort of like a German name I
don't recognize it I don't recognise it
as either what do you think he's got no
Helen yeah no no no help okay I'm
thankful I'm gonna say he's a cyclist
okay let's go with Phil and what do you
say del - phone I said pharmaceutical ah
Phil Keoghan helps out Chris Rock man
the genic sidewalk for the Czech
Republic article SATA a quick Bell floor
job okay that was a bit of a guess I got
to be on here we go
well done Brockman's up 1-nothing europe
first brockman bRILINTA oh that sounds
like a farm boy linty pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical I'm on that and factly
you take that totally for my suit Alex
it's about lowering the risk of stroke
or serious heart problems after I've had
a heart attack or angina please consult
your doctor before taking brought up and
yes okay next up your one behind Phil -
Phil you're up first
Emden Emden EMD en cyclists are
pharmaceutical
well what do you think we got a cyclist
a pharmaceutical Phil Keoghan I just put
me on the spot with that one hmm
Cogan I'm dr. reichman's he says go with
a cyclist you say cyclists are you gonna
phone a friend and tell the friend he
doesn't know anything he's the director
of Laurent yeah but that doesn't make it
right oh you go with me Morris suit
achill Rahman cyclist Joseph nm VIN part
of team motto from the Netherlands I was
going to say Jeremy's brockman car five
scho Cogan will be the Blessed Rock you
merely information I don't get in my
teeth I know last one try and make a
game of it the test Oh oh that's so
pharmaceutical or cyclists
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical it is
nasal testosterone good job rotten dirty
by the way consult your doctor after
completing stage 14 before you take the
test oh the nasal testosterone get your
popular tortoise Ron pharmaceutical or
cycling or cyclists what do you think so
I'm impressed you guys I thought you
guys did pretty well yeah came back to
Bertram should we put should we should
we picked that on a major brand monitor
and a lease dog in the area is that one
they'd love it right tell me about
what's going on on the Smithsonian
Channel flying high with Phil Keoghan
for fly let you go so I'm from New
Zealand yes indeed I was asked to direct
a one-hour aerial show over New Zealand
flying for four days five days actually
over New Zealand so every single shot an
aerial of New Zealand and and I've
always wanted to do a show about the
personalities of different of different
countries you know what is it that
epitomizes different countries around
the world
so I shot a special with 12 New
Zealanders including Peter Jackson Sam
Neill
my dad some comedians a guy who rounds
up sheep with a drone so it's a fun so
from the Academy award-winning director
of the Lord of the Rings trilogy yeah we
see her the guy who's sheeps her
grounding us
okay yeah and actually have a lot more
running the gamut so they say they have
a lot more in common than you might
imagine
but but what I did was with Sam Neil was
I went to his vineyard he has a he grows
beautiful Pinot Noir grapes two paddocks
that's the name of the vineyard and then
with Peter Jackson instead of talking
about movies I talked about his World
War one plane collection he has over 70
World War one planes and we actually go
flying in one of them so the idea is
with famous people is to kind of talk
about things that they don't normally
talk about so please tell me one of
Peter Jackson's planes it's called the
precious please tell me that that you
flew it should be right appreciation
yeah you're right I'm Phil Keoghan I
yeah Samuel by the way the the actor
played the the Red October
the red officer yeah the the Red October
defector who never saw Montana which is
one of the saddest lines yeah never
member that is no I got you you never
seen I've never seen the film I don't
think so no one could you see he's the
facility sv-1 getting one thing they
only one thing he was in Jurassic Park
he was in peaky blinders by the way
great characters in peaky blinders
amazing actor 1990 I was doing other
stuff that year Oh 1990 were you even
born yeah you know I wanted a you know
feel loved having you on man wanna make
you feel better
come back any time but how can people
check out larog Holly check it out the
ride is in theatres all around the
country if you go to Phil Keoghan 'la
ride calm you'll see where it's
screening and we're working with a
company where you can actually demand a
screening in a theatre in your local
town and you want and then the other
show flying high on Smithsonian Channel
August 6 burger yeah I'd love love Bo
you tune in to see that as well you got
it Phil Keoghan here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that download our app please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the rich eyes and show app you
need that